here to present the Award for Best
Supporting Actress please welcome last
year's Best Supporting Actor mr. Kevin
Spacey
I'm here - apparently you didn't hear
the news from Crown Heights we're not
allowed to wear this anymore
I myself have enjoyed my two days as a
Gentile
I had a great Palm Sunday I even enjoyed
a daiquiri and tomorrow I made my retail
are you done yet just having such a good
time boy would you do me a favor I want
to keep the actresses waiting but would
you would you do this as Christopher
Walken
he's also it's a Best Supporting Actor
Oh Billy come on it's wrong of you to
put me on the spot here in front of all
these people
tonight it's wrong I like that I'm upset
don't be upset no I am I turned down
Sling Blade I said no I thought another
psychopathic killer I cannot do and now
look America loves him it's wrong
on to the business at hand I am here to
present the Oscar for an actress in a
supporting role these are my fellow
alumni of high school drama clubs who
have already won our admiration and
respect in supporting roles performed
with the brilliance of these five
artists they have done for film what the
Cheshire Cat did for Alice they have
left an indelible impression the
nominees for Best Performance by an
actress in a supporting role are Joan
Allen in the crucible Lauren Bacall in
the mirror has two faces Juliette
Binoche in the English Patient
Barbara Hershey in the portrait of a
lady
Marianne jean-baptiste in secrets and
lies
and the Oscar goes to Juliette Binoche
in the English Patient
I'm so surprised it's true I didn't
prepare anything
I thought Lauren was going to get it and
I think she deserves it
I think we all tried our best on this
film and Antony was there to help us I'm
so amazed this is a dream it must be a
French dream I think by